cave-dwelling carnivores parental
possessions psychologists chased by
Psychopaths it's all been done before
and done again
leave it to the film industry to release
two radically similar movies a month
apart when M Night shyamalan's filmed
the Sixth Sense hit big screens
everywhere it became a sensation it
largely did so by positioning itself as
a horror film then shifting gears and
turning into a thriller The Narrative
twist is considered one of M Night
shyamalan's best on-screen magic tricks
and Word of Mouth made audiences feel
like they had to see it putting the
director on the map however many fans
forget that another film one with a
better pedigree was released around the
same time and was devoured in its wake
get to it please
Stir of Echoes is based on Richard
Matheson's classic novel the film
adaptation was directed by one of the
most successful screenwriters of all
time David Kapp and stars Kevin Bacon
the film follows Tom a working-class man
who lives in Chicago with his pregnant
wife during a gathering one evening Tom
allows his sister-in-law Lisa to
hypnotize him while susceptible to
hypnotic suggestion Lisa tells Tom to be
more open-minded afterward he begins
seeing frightful visions of the Dead
however just like the Sixth Sense The
Apparition isn't necessarily harmful
both films feature lead characters who
can converse with the dead ultimately
helping the spirits resolve their
worldly issues these similarities beg
the question why did The Sixth Sense
gross about 32 times more at the
worldwide box office than its ghostly
counterpart
these two voyeuristic Tales take people
watching to the next level in 1954
Alfred Hitchcock released his now
classic Thriller rear window about a man
recovering from a broken leg in his
apartment to pass the time he begins
watching his neighbors out of his rear
window when one neighbor's wife
disappears the protagonist becomes
increasingly convinced that he witnessed
a murder eventually roping his
girlfriend into the suspicion as well 53
years later Shia LaBeouf would star in
Disturbia a film about a troubled teen
reeling from the recent passing of his
father remanded to house arrest and
similarly passing the time by people
watching LaBeouf's character begins to
feel there's something off about the man
next door it's a paranoid Thriller for
the new century and was one of the early
films that helped Propel the buff into
stardom Disturbia stirred some
controversy in the film industry when it
was released while rear window is based
on Cornell woolrich's 1942 story it had
to be murder a 2008 lawsuit was filed
against Steven Spielberg and DreamWorks
alleging that the studio had made
Disturbia without obtaining the rights
to adapt the same story the claim was
ultimately rejected with the U.S
District Court Judge Laura Taylor Swann
writing the main plots are similar only
at a high unprotectable level of
generality where Disturbia is ripe with
subplots the short story has none the
setting and mood of the short story are
static intense whereas the setting and
mood of Disturbia are more Dynamic and
peppered with humor and teen romance
in the second half of the 20th century
the idea of Satanism began to take hold
as a threat to Americans laying the
groundwork for the infamous satanic
Panic of the 80s when Roman Polanski
released Rosemary's Baby it was a huge
hit the film starred Mia Farrow and John
cassavetes as a young couple living in
an upscale apartment in New York City
featuring many cryptic horrific moments
that ultimately lead to Rosemary
becoming impregnated with the son of
Satan decades later it Still Remains a
discomforting watch hail Satan Satan is
his father and his name is Adrian he
shall overthrow the mighty and lay waste
their temples in 1976 Richard Donner's
The Omen was dropped into the middle of
this moment with strong groundwork
already laid for many of its terrifying
themes following Gregory Peck and Lee
Remick as they experience a deceptive
childbirth that might just lead to them
possessing the son of Satan the theme
was unmistakably similar to Rosemary's
Baby both films essentially tell the
same story ending on the same ominous
idea the Antichrist has been been born
and the world is about to be plunged
Into Darkness
John Krasinski blew audiences away with
2018's a quiet place which he wrote and
directed the film features a
post-apocalyptic World ravaged by blind
otherworldly creatures hunting and
killing anything that makes a noise
Krasinski also starred in the film as a
survivalist Family Man guiding his
family in the ways of this new reality
the family's daughter is deaf making her
uniquely suited for Humanity's response
to their new Predator it was a
pulse-pounding movie sure to give
viewers a few gray hairs
in 2019 Netflix released the film The
Silence barely a year after Netflix's
Bird Box had become a hit as another
sensory driven horror film The Silence
features a family caught in a
post-apocalyptic world where a strange
species of creatures from underground
have emerged known as fesps they
viciously hunt and kill based on sound
and seek the areas with the most noise
for hunting protagonist Hugh played by
Stanley Tucci must work to ensure his
and his family's survival interestingly
enough Hugh's daughter Ali is also deaf
in Thrillers like these it seems
screenwriters are very quietly stealing
from each other
ready for a claustrophobic Adventure in
the deep dark underground if so then
these two films are for you however
there's far more to be afraid of than
tight spaces and getting lost in the
darkness in these Subterranean Thrillers
the 2005 Neil Marshall Break Out The
Descent depicts a group of Thrill
Seekers who decide to explore a strange
cave system in an unsurprising turn of
events they encounter predatory
creatures long trapped underground which
hunt by using sound 2005's the cave
follows explorers who attempt to
investigate a cave system that has been
covered for many years deep below the
surface they soon discover that they've
entered the domain of horrific creatures
never before discovered by man who
quickly develop a taste for the
spelunkers during their desperate fight
for survival the remaining survivors
learned that these creatures were once
human but have been transformed by an
unknown parasite which film pulled the
concept off better if you aren't already
feeling claustrophobic take a look for
yourself they'd make a great double
feature
Ed and Lorraine Warren became household
names with the Cinematic depiction of
their paranormal exploits in The
Conjuring reportedly they were involved
in a myriad of other Supernatural
investigations including the Enfield
haunting and an investigation into a
certain haunted home in Amityville New
York that connection aside both The
Conjuring and the Amityville Horror have
strikingly similar premises 2013's The
Conjuring depicts The Haunting of the
parent family after they move into a new
home in Rhode Island the home was once
property of a witch by the name of
Bathsheba who killed her baby in the
name of the devil before cursing the
plot of land and taking her own life the
Warrens revealed that the spirit
haunting the parent home is malevolent
it eventually attempts to possess the
matriarch of the family and force her to
sacrifice her own child The Amityville
Horror also has a chilling real-life
backstory the film depicts the Lutz
family who move into a home where one
year earlier Ronnie defeo murdered his
entire family soon after moving in the
family begins to experience paranormal
phenomena the father George Lutz played
by by James Brolin slowly becomes
murderous possessed by the dark Forces
to harm his family I wouldn't hurt you
trauma often impacts people in different
ways and can take the form of fixations
or possible agoraphobia that's the case
for Dr Helen Hudson in copycat the
would-be victim of an ex-convict Helen's
criminal psychology expertise allows her
to better understand serial killers
she's then consulted by a homicide
detective to help solve a recent string
of murders what she ultimately realizes
is that the murders are all copycat acts
of other notorious Killers such as the
Hillside Strangler Jeffrey Dahmer and
Ted Bundy eventually the murderer begins
targeting Helen and everything the
perpetrator does is connected to a
recent lecture she gave on serial
killers copycat may not have been a hit
in fact many have probably forgotten
about it but Netflix's 2021 film The
Woman in the window has a lot in common
with its 1995 predecessor the movie
features a child psychologist named Anna
played by Amy Adams who is similarly
agoraphobic due to past trauma and finds
herself observing her neighbors in her
lonely State at one point Anna Witnesses
the murder of a woman on her street
after authorities tell her that nothing
happened she become a bit unsure of her
experiences later it is revealed that
just like Dr Hudson and copycat a killer
is targeting Anna and has been toying
with her in this case the similarities
between the two films are every bit as
fishy as they feel the woman in the
window is based on a novel of the same
name by AJ Finn which is a pen name for
Dan Mallory he endured a public
relations nightmare after his book was
published and it was revealed that he
had been hiding the fact that he had
lifted plot points from you guessed it
copycat
while certainly not one of the most
beloved M Night Shyamalan films The
Happening did cause a stir among Avid
moviegoers drawn to its haunting
trailers starring Mark Wahlberg and Zoe
Deschanel the film depicts a couple
attempting to find safety from a strange
plague that causes Ordinary People to
fatally harm themselves beneath the
violence and Terror the film also sends
a message about nature fighting back
it's a strange film with an even
stranger premise
no
I don't know Bird Box was released on
Netflix in 2018 and it seemed to share a
lot of DNA with the Shyamalan film Bird
Box follows Sandra Bullock and her
children as they seek a safe haven from
an apocalyptic condition that has swept
the entire Globe something is causing
people to take their own lives which
occurs once they see it so in an effort
to protect themselves survivors blind
themselves employing bandanas or
blindfolds to make sure they never
Glimpse the evil creatures it's a
harrowing film that promotes curiosity
over its biggest mysteries long after
the credits roll
[Music]